i'm going to be taking your calls in 15  minutes via the official david pakman  show discord which you can find at  davidpakman.com  discord if you want to talk to me uh get  on the discord  get into the waiting lobby click the  waiting lobby and  make sure your name on the server  is in the format name from town  so like i would put you know david from  buenos aires  argentina or whatever you can change the  way your nickname looks in my server by  right-clicking your name and clicking on  change nickname so again that's  davidpakman.com  discord click on the waiting lobby  and change your nickname to be your name  and the town you're from or calling in  from  or however you want to be mentioned when  i go to you  look forward to speaking to you very  soon